[Musique]
ils sont tous là plus d'une cinquantaine
d'organismes professionnels agricoles
dans l'hémicycle du palais de la source
des prescripteurs du monde agricole qui
viennent rencontrer l'autorité de
gestion du feader le département que
l'on fait doit d'être présent évidemment
pour faire le relais auprès de nos
adhérents donc sur le terrain pour qu'on
évidemment qu'on consomme les enveloppes
fallait bien que le bio fasse partie du
pdr de la réunion plan de développement
rural de la réunion on avait besoin
expliqué notamment à tout ce qui gravite
autour des aides européennes
les échanges sont techniques chacun
partage son vécu la méthode
ok mon avis elle est bonne parce que la
profession est beaucoup liée donc on est
un vrai partenaire ou non
au niveau du conseil départemental
maintenant il ya des règles européennes
à respecter on peut pas passer outre
malheureusement je crois qu'on a une
bonne une bonne cohésion sur le travail
d'équipé réalisé que le conseil
départemental c'est vrai que quand il ya
beaucoup d'intermédiaires ça peut
vraisemblablement compliquer la méthode
parce qu'il faut faire de plus en plus
de réunions ça c'est certain
il faut quand même apprendre de nos
erreurs et j'espère que pour le prochain
le prochain prochaine pac qui entre
guillemets politique agricole commune
on anticipe mieux et qu'on avance plus
facilement grâce à nos sentiments dire
que peut-être qu auparavant on avait
plutôt tendance à réunir les cadeaux ou
autre mais celui qui en liaison directe
avec l'agriculteur et qui remonte
éventuellement les difficultés finale là
on m'a donné l'occasion nous en donne
l'occasion de participer au pilotage
important car pour rappel le feader et
doté de 385 5 millions d'euros et si à
ce jour 95 % des dispositifs sont
ouverts uniquement 21 % de l'enveloppé
programme est essentiel de communiquer
et de bien communiquer pour tordre le
cou à la désinformation
je crois que ça c'est essentiel lorsque
nous sommes dans une position d'autorité
de gestion où nous gérons défaut donc
c'était important de communiquer et
d'informer sur ces évolutions positives
que nous avons eues sur la mise en
oeuvre des fonds européens afin
d'améliorer la compétitivité de
l'agriculture réunionnaise de gérer
durablement les ressources de développer
les hauts de l'île ou encore de soutenir
la production locale
ces points de rencontre sont essentiels
pour l'avenir
[Musique]